on est tombé sur un article qui parle de
la danse la plus sexy au monde sait les
chercheurs anglais qui ont fait danser
39 personnes séparément ils ont modélisé
en 3d
ces danses et les ont montrés à 200
personnes hommes et femmes
ils ont sélectionné la meilleure celle
que la majorité trouve la plus sexy et
c'est celle-là vous a essayé de
reproduire dans un instant et les
chroniqueurs vont chacun essayer de
reproduire leur danse la plus sexy dans
un instant pour le moment regardez
magali et vous allez essayer de faire la
même chose
[Musique]
voilà alors vous avez vu la danseuse
sexy donc c'est simple tu as à l'équipe
à gagner à l'exil est laissé pas mal
gardée dire également foot et magali
qu'on peut dire qu'il sera notre public
aujourd'hui version iphone sort
tranquille parce que là vous allez voir
des professionnels de la danse
attention c'est parti on démarre par le
premier chroniqueur je ne sais pas qui
va arriver c'est parti lors de sa pêche
etc si on y va
[Musique]
mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas sorcier
hypo gaza il est beau gosse mois pour
être gardés dans ces camps le voilà mes
heures et des heures
ouais ouais ouais
l avenir l on sait pas faire si c'est
bon vous votez chez vous pour celui ou
celle qui a fait la danse la plus sexy
aujourd'hui on rase et et bernard
montiel merci bernard applaudir la halle
et attention deuxième deuxième chronique
ans va prendre et était très bonne
[Musique]
l'élégant l'élégant la caméra il a fait
40 ans c'est pas mal c'était la dose est
plus centré pour mes mots je crois que
c'est beaucoup pour la danse la plus
sensuelle mais voilà c'était la danse a
plus besoin de regarder sur internet
c'était savez ce que j'aime ça il ya de
nouvelles danses ça vous bougez
autrement les deux vous proposer autre
chose
c'est vraiment ça allait troisième
chroniqueurs
[Musique]
c'est la grâce et la grâce ah oui
la glace et al gore et la mythique
c'est pas mal mais c'est très bien très
bien
je crie ça j'arrête babioles
n'éclabousse citoyens c'est pas mal à
l'aller l'ol est allé dans le public
j'ai juste soir je n'aime pas trop ça
nous fait plaisir que vous soyez là
façon ses licenciés allez c'est parti
chaque candidat d'alors
pedro l'intérieur
ce permis
[Musique]
à
et lui dise on dirait que chacun sache
c'est moi qui la montrent l atout tout
en attaquant la tristesse et le pire
jusqu'à présent pas oui magali souvent
là y penser pour l'instant
alors c'est vrai que jean michel mr sam
et chroniqueurs préférés
mais là pour le coup un petit magasin
allez c'est parti prochain chroniqueurs
[Musique]
la cocof
ça fait sens
obama sait pas
sexy sexy
c'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus assez
sexy cyril vous êtes très dur surtout
pour c'est mon ami talons vous on est
pas doué comme vous on aimait les
animaux arrêtez arrêtez laver sans vous
la danse est pas prête à laisser partir
le prochain on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
magali la caisse colis ah ben là c'est
que du kif oui vous voyez la deux qui
sont détachés c'est kelly et les monts
oui mais enfin il fait son grand retour
aujourd'hui après deux mois de vacances
à la campagne
il revient et il revient plus sexy que
jamais il est très anxieux de leur beau
c'est parti il a fait
[Rires]
voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
[Applaudissements]
ouais bah tu arrêter je vais arrêter
deux minutes la musique
mathieu pourquoi sa part toujours bien
et ça c'est mon heat n'ont put on
demande le même sketch à chaque fois
parce que votre talent et si c'est oui
c'est votre tour les échos quand
j'arrive en boîte et les boîtes de 2 3
me de versailles n'apparaissent qu'une
de sel je leur ai poche nickel inside
and alors allez-y allez-y bacula il a
bien marché
[Applaudissements]